parents and kids and teachers and
individual schools who are truly seeing
their lives and and communities changed
as a result of freedom and education
I would argue that school choice week
has been the most successful example of
bringing together people together in a
collaborative way because we're not
competing for research or funders we all
have picked a few days to highlight our
own organization and what we do just to
improve opportunity for kids so it
becomes a very collaborative effort so
an example of that so you look at the so
reason works with school choice week one
of the things that we do is we try to
use the reason TV videos and journalism
to highlight some of the opportunities
for school choice so obviously the
Alabama school choice rally was an
example of that and I personally have
built so many new relationships over the
last five years with people all over the
country because of these working
together on these events and working to
film these events and working to tell
these stories so just last week the
Alabama Senate passed a new charter
school law in the state of Alabama and
one of the reasons that Alabama was one
of the states that we were working in is
it's one of only eight states in the
united states that do not have charter
school legislation so they have no
charter schools and they really have
almost no educational opportunities
outside of homeschooling or parents
private paying they still have basically
a monopoly of the education
establishment and so kids disadvantaged
kids really don't have anywhere to go
and actually in getting this charter
school bill through the Senate which it
looks likely that it also passed through
the house and that it actually will go
this year and they will have a charter
school bill but many of the folks that
participated in the rally and some of
the principals and parents that
participated in the school choice week
event were then the witnesses that went
and testified about their own
experiences working in schools with
their own families in front of the
Alabama Senate to get the bill passed so
this just shows you know that we're not
just doing this to you know
have beautiful yellow scarves and bring
people together but we actually are
working to build coalitions for
institutional change and Alabama is an
example of where that's actually working
we're going to get the first charter
school bill passed in the state so now
I'm going to switch now and talk a
little bit about why do we want markets
and education in the United States what
is the problem so here we have the
robert e kennedy community schools a new
school in the last couple of years in
los angeles that was built at the site
of the old ambassador hotel for a
bargain basement price of 578 million
dollars for one school in the united
states and the working theory in los
angeles unified seems to be that if you
have 20 billion dollars in bonds to have
the largest public works financing
program in the united states and you
build a lot of new schools that are
really pretty and expensive that
children will learn that seems to be the
school districts working theory as far
as i can tell here's the teachers lounge
at the robert kennedy school the working
theory here seems to be that if you have
an opulent beautiful teachers lounge
that teacher quality will improve and
that kids will have good teachers here's
the student theatre for their high
school productions at the robert kennedy
school one of the most expensive high
school theaters that you will find in
the nation and so having really another
thing they have is they have a kitchen
at this high school that would rival the
food network in which you know literally
they're teaching kids to cook in
facilities that are multi-million
dollars and as far as i can tell robert
e kennedy high school does not actually
have a Food Network show that would
warrant the expense of the kitchens
so what about so here is the deal a
little dirty secret about LA Unified is
it's like Detroit in a lot of other
urban areas while they have had this
twenty billion dollar building program
they've lost about two hundred thousand
kids to charter schools so they have and
actually closed older schools but
they've opened a lot of new schools in
the district and so they're really they
have lots of schools that are at forty
percent capacity or fifty percent
capacity and then actually when the
Robert Kennedy School opened they didn't
actually know who would go to school
there and so they bid it out and they
started five schools that cochere the
building and right now we're on a
testing break in the state of California
it looks like we didn't have any test
scores last year and we won't have them
this year and maybe by 2017 we will have
sorted out our implementation of common
core and we will have some data to look
at about how students in California are
doing but right now to 2013 was our last
year of test scores and you can see the
schools that occupy and I say that
ironically the robert f kennedy
community schools they all minus 27
points from one year to the next minus 5
minus 12 minus 8-17 the only school that
is gaining in terms of student
achievement on this state score that
kind of aggregates all testing in a
school is the new open world academy
which is like a frightening name for
school but they are in elementary school
and one of the things we know about
school reform is the most intractable
and most difficult kids to raise their
test scores are middle and high school
and it's relatively easy for a short
time to have improvement with elementary
school kids so the elementary school
kids at the school is are doing okay the
robert kennedy school really signifies
what's happened over the last few
decades in the united states so i'm
committing a
um some kind of a mortal sin by showing
a slide from the Cato Institute at a
reason weekend event but Andrew Colson
who is an education director there he
has done a lot of work to kind of
quantify how we've been doing and what
you see the blue line is the total cost
of education the first one going way up
in 1970 adjusted for inflation it cost
about fifty eight thousand dollars to
send a kid for their lifetime of there K
through 12 education every year and in
2010 it cost about 165,000 dollars for a
lifetime of K through 12 education the
red line is how much staffing has gone
up way more people work in the schools
the next one that's going up the dotted
line is how much enrollment is gone up
since 1970 so you can see the red line
with staffing has gone up a lot more
than the enrollment line so we have wave
more adults that we're paying to work
with a relatively flat number of kids
and then the green and the red and the
purplish line that's all student
achievement for 17 year olds on the
National Assessment of Education
progress so we can see that we used to
an inflation-adjusted dollars spend a
lot less to get the exact same outcomes
for 17 year olds in terms of reading
math and science similarly this next
slide is just federal spending and the
federal government used to give K
through 12 a lot less money than they do
now and again federal spending has shot
through the ceiling and all of those
academic performance on the nape for 17
year olds are still flat in reading math
in science so we've spent a lot of money
we haven't seen a lot of improvement and
that's basically why we want more
competition besides the fact that
obviously want parents to have choice
and control their kids destinies and we
want schools to look more like pop-tarts
and less like
the one plain sad pop tart with no
frosting on it here we have how much we
spend in the United States on k-12
education compared to the rest of the
world and really where we go along with
Switzerland as the top spending of all
developed countries OECD and so not only
do we spend a lot and we spend a lot
over time we spend more than anyone else
in the world on education and this is
kind of complicated but basically what
the OECD did is they tried to figure out
do nations like the United States that
spend so much more actually perform
better than other nations that spend
less and what they found is that
countries that spend more than a hundred
thousand dollars for the lifetime of the
kids education so remember we're at
about 165,000 in the United States do
they outscore other countries that spend
about half of that so Hungary Poland
Estonia they spend about fifty percent
of what we do for the cumulative
lifetime of a kid and guess what it
turns out that there's top performers
that spend less than us and you don't
get any added value for spending more
than those countries that spend fifty
percent of what we spend if that makes
sense so countries that are spending
around 50,000 or performing the same as
countries that are spending about a
hundred thousand so we have an
internationally added value by spending
so much more on education so what if we
have school choice and the money follows
the child what happens then you know is
that a good thing should we do that
first where are we at in terms of market
share so last time that we were here we
did not have 51 school choice programs
that included private schools so this
includes 23 voucher
programs 18 tax credit programs and to
education savings accounts which is the
biggest new innovation in education
choice that I'll talk about at the end
so we have about 300,000 kids that go to
private voucher programs now that's not
very many considering how many kids are
in public schools in the United States
but then when we move and then we see
over time that we've had a lot of growth
in the number of kids in private school
choice programs but then when we move to
charter schools a lot of people think of
charter schools is a more less robust
more marginal school choice program and
they are regulated more than other kinds
of schools but in the end charter
schools actually do have the money for
the child because if the kid doesn't
enroll in the school it works a lot like
a voucher it's just that they have to
follow more regulation and they also
have to be authorized by the government
so they have to get permission to
operate from the government so we're
always fighting for that permission but
they've grown by 6700 public charter
schools 2.9 million kids the newest
figures five percent of public schools
and a feature not a bug of charter
schools is that when they underperform
they actually close so last year 200
charter schools were closed for low
performance financial difficulties and
low enrollment and not one school in
compton unified was closed or in harlem
was closed part of the national school
choice week we put together an info
graph about charter schools and one of
the things that they do is they produce
better results than traditional public
schools for less money so they get about
thirty percent less funding as public
schools than traditional public schools
and a study of the National Assessment
of education progress found that for
every thousand dollars in school funds
they produced on average higher scores
in both reading and math 16 points in
reading and 17 points in math
for every that's not bad on a national
test that everyone takes they're also
more diverse you often hear that they
cream or that somehow they are not
representative of their communities or
that they segregate kids but when we
look at them on the whole they actually
have more diversity than traditional
public schools they really work well for
minority kids low-income blacks gain
equivalent of 7.5 extra weeks of math
instruction and 6.5 of reading low
income hispanic students five extra
weeks and three extra weeks and
traditional public schools New Orleans
which we talked about the last time we
met on the last report of charter school
market share they had ninety-one percent
of their kids enrolled in charter
schools and other cities like Washington
DC Cleveland Detroit Los Angeles a huge
number of kids competing with
traditional public schools and new
orleans is now at a hundred percent
because they just closed the last three
traditional schools that were run by the
recovery school district we can see that
in 2005 when the charter school miracle
started in New Orleans 9262 percent of
the schools were failing now it's down
to five percent on the same state
metrics in New Orleans so they've had a
ninety-two percent reduction in failing
schools and that five percent is even
less because those schools that were
closed that are now charter schools
would be in that five percent they used
to rank 67th out of 68 districts in 2003
they had risen to thirty-eight percent
which you know is a huge gain over five
years in terms of or more than five
years but in eight years basically
they've gained to the middle of the pack
and again we're having a testing crisis
in the United States where we don't have
information after 2013 because of Common
Core so it's hard for us to say how
things are going in Louisiana or and
we're moving forward and then I'll just
close with the this school in Chicago
they sent a hundred percent of students
to college five years in a row and this
may you know we talked about the college
bubble we tend to get grumpy about it
but for students that will never have
this opportunity we're charter schools
are really excelling they're doing okay
for the same money with student
achievement but they have 20-point
advantages in terms of high school
graduation same with school voucher
programs in Milwaukee they have twenty
or thirty point advantages in terms of
college attainment so where these are
long-term goals I mean a math score for
a seventeen-year-old is important but in
the United States going to college
arguably gives you lifetime financial
benefits and then I'm just going to
close with the newest form of school
choice and I know education savings
accounts instead of the idea of school
choice we've moved to the idea of
educational choice we're not only would
you have school choice to go to a school
you just should have the money in a
savings account where if you want a
tutor you need an occupational therapist
you want to get some downloaded classes
from Stanford you want to go half day to
private school you could completely
customize your child's education and you
would have and then the money you had
leftover would roll over into a savings
account and this can be funded through
public school tuition like it like a
voucher or it can be funded through a
tax credit program where the tax credit
which is completely private goes into
the education savings account and
companies may donate for low-income kids
and that goes into the education savings
account and then if their parents are
efficient they can then save the money
and roll it over towards college from
year to year they don't spend the full
amount of education savings account and
so right now Arizona in Florida are the
only two states that have education
savings accounts but those in the blue
and purple ish those are the states that
either have current bills in the 2015
legislative session or they are see
basically considering filing bills
towards education savings accounts so
school choice is winning we've made a
lot of progress just since 2011 and now
andrew is going to talk a little bit
about the national school choice week
campaign as lisa has described there
really is right now an abundance of
school choice across the country and
from where I sit and in my job which I
have to say is the best job in the
entire world because I get to help plan
a series of awesome parties every year
promoting school choice and at the same
time help tell the stories of parents
and kids and teachers and individual
schools who are truly seeing their lives
and and communities changed as a result
of freedom and education and I think
that if we look at the growth of school
choice in America today and also the
demand for school choice in individual
communities across the country we have
the potential to see right now in the
next five to ten years an exponential
growth in the amount of school choice
and I think one of the reasons we're
going to see that is number one we've
reached a tipping point in terms of how
many people are benefitting from school
choice parents are seeing other parents
actually being able to choose the right
schools for their kids as opposed to
being stuck in some arbitrary zip code
you know mandated schools that's number
one number two so many so-called reforms
recently whether it's testing as Lisa
talked about with new standards have
really not been popular with parents the
new standards program has not been
implemented as effectively as it could
have been and people frankly are really
mad they want more options and school
choice in my view and in the view I hope
of many of you here is the single
catalytic reform it's the reform giving
parents freedom and opportunity to
reform that can get all other reforms
done because it is the reform that
parents understand they understand that
if they choose the right school for
their child great things will happen
what makes a lot more sense to
individual parents in local communities
than teacher quality reform standard
reforms test
reforms spending reforms things like
that choice is truly the great equalizer
so with that I want to talk about why
national school choice week exists and
how we play a role in this overall
movement because as much as I'd love to
take credit for the growth in school
choice it has something to do it with me
really it has to do with individual
parents and students and school choice
week came about because we recognize
folks recognize about five years ago
that there were three major barriers to
the long-term systemic growth of the
broader school choice movement and
that's not just private school choice
but in the public sector as well so
public school choice programs charter
schools magnet schools virtual schools
again private school choice vouchers tax
credits home schooling all of those
things the three barriers that existed
in the movement were first of all the
movement focused far too much in the
past on organizations at the national
level at the expense of state level
organizations and individual parents the
interests and views and needs of
individual parents were often left
behind you know in favor of a more I
guess high-minded policy discussion now
reason is a great exception to that rule
they're able to sell the policy of
school choice in a much more effective
way the second thing I would say is that
for too long the school choice movement
which is really not it has not been a
real movement for that long of a period
of time because you have all these
different sectors and factions within
the movement and they haven't been
getting along so getting folks to build
coalitions and get along has been
essential to the growth of this movement
and the creation of an actual movement
and the third thing is that nobody
within the school choice realm really
wanted to do marketing everybody wanted
to talk about policies and how do we
create the best bill and how do we
create the best model for implementation
but heck if you don't sell something to
the general public and to real parents
in local communities and all you do is
talk about it I say this as I'm talking
about it you end up with a situation
where people don't understand what
you're trying to promote to them
so marketing has been something that the
school choice movement did not do very
well for a while so a few years ago five
years ago folks said let's try to let's
try to knock those barriers down bring
people together start promoting school
choice in an understandable digestible
and in some cases fun way and national
school choice week was born and the goal
of school choice week is really to
empower parents and teachers and
administrators in all different types of
schools and outside of schools to hold
events where they celebrate school
choice where it exists and demand it
where it does not during one week out of
the year and the goal is to start tens
of thousands if not millions of
individual conversations about
educational freedom and then aggregate
all of those stories into an effective
national celebration and we do that
every year in January and we're now as
Lisa said in our fifth year and we do
have five key goals to school choice
week we want to increase public
awareness and demand for school choice
so really letting parents know that they
do have choices where they send their
kids to school and in many play many
places parents don't know the choices
they have so we're trying to let people
know you do have choices in many cases
and then let them know also if you want
more choices like parents have in other
areas stand up have your voices heard
speak out contact your legislators and
demand greater options we want to
encourage the creation and the you know
development of coalition's of school
choice organizations specifically in
states so bringing together these
different sectors and factions whether
it's the open enrollment crowd in public
schools magnet schools charter schools
the voucher proponents the homeschooling
advocates honestly I see I've seen more
fights with in those five or six sectors
than you do between the school choice
crowd and the opposition and we can't
have that type of fighting so we want to
create these coalition's so that when it
comes time to pass crucial legislation
folks are actually getting along
strengthing strengthening bipartisan
alliance is very important so this isn't
just viewed as a Republican issue but an
issue where it's safe for Democrats to
come on board and
prove to America that the school choice
movement is actually a movement and it
isn't just people talking about this
issue in very narrowly defined ways so
that's the goal of school choice week or
the five key goals of school choice week
and let's see how we've done over the
last five years so this year we were
able to work with folks all across the
country to encourage the planning of
more than 11,000 events across the
country we doubled the number of events
from last year and since 2011 we've
grown from as Lisa mentioned a hundred
and fifty events so pretty exciting to
do that and the one thing I wanted to
mention about these events and we'll
talk about where these events come from
and who's planning them what they look
like in a second but the exciting part
about school choice week isn't that is
that these events are independently
planned and independently funded and we
are really cautious about making sure
that we don't tell people what they have
to do you can plan any type of event for
school choice week that you want it's
almost like new year's eve everybody
celebrating it but everybody has a
different type of party so people can
plan rallies at schools open houses pep
rallies they can do national school
choice week flash dance they can go to
their state capitol and rally for change
they can contact their legislators they
can hold a carnival we have people doing
anything to raise awareness in their
local communities and by allowing people
to do that and by saying listen we're
not going to tell you what to do you
celebrate your own way we're helping to
create dialogues in local communities
that help inform parents in those
communities about what's available to
them and what they could have if they
had more options so we have school
participation and this year 9600 schools
held events everything from private
schools to charter schools magnet
schools traditional public schools and
online academies we also work with
organizations everything from local
chambers of commerce to business
organizations to think tanks to school
choice organizations charter school
associations and encourage them to hold
events throughout the year I'm not
throughout the year throughout the week
a lot of organizations don't usually
plan events they don't usually organized
celebratory types of things and
it's been a struggle in many ways to get
folks on board to do things but we think
we found the solution this year where we
encourage folks to talk about school
choice as part of an already planned
meeting and that's this my meeting
program we've created so we had more
than 500 groups across the country
talking about school choice in their
local communities during school choice
week now of these 11,000 events i
mentioned that they're all independently
planned independently funded and they
are really autonomous we don't set too
many rules but there are some states
where we work and try to help build
really strong coalitions and help foster
events so that these coalition's will
plan their own events but will provide
some support and this year we did that
in the form of rally celebrations at
state capitols and you saw a video that
reason did about the event in Montgomery
Alabama which was the biggest one this
year with 5,000 participants this year
we worked in 15 different states with
more than a hundred different
organizations in those states bringing
people together from all different
sectors of school choice in education
reform and the goal again is not just to
hold a celebratory event but it's to
bring people together who they might
work in the same city and in the same
state but because they're on different
different factions different sectors
they never go to each other's offices
and it's a lot easier to get them to sit
down and plan an event and choose what
type of you know rally sign they want
and where they you know want to start
the March or the rally at or whether
they want to give out bottled water or
not making little decisions like that
then saying okay let's sit down and
craft a piece of legislation so you get
people to start planning a party they
become friends and they start working
together year round and I'll talk to you
a little bit about some of the impact
that we've seen from those coalition's
so very very successful program thanks
to all those partners we work with this
year we also have elected officials
involved doing proclamations and
interestingly enough we actually have
more Democrats on the mayoral mayoral
side doing proclamations recognizing
school choice week and more Republicans
on the gubernatorial side and for the
first time ever this year the US Senate
unanimously and with bipartisan support
when it came to
solution being introduced passed a
resolution recognizing school choice
week throughout the country we have
strong online outreach efforts because
again we focus on individuals and what
matters to individual families and we
saw for example more people search for
school choice on Google during school
choice week this year than at any other
time during the last five years so we
know that of our goals were seeing the
first to increasing interest and
increasing demand go up Shirley by the
amount of interest on Google we also
trended on Twitter which is I don't know
how important that is but it was fun and
one of the ways were number three after
bell let's talk I don't know what any of
that is but and another goal one of the
metrics that we use to figure out
whether or not school choice week is
successful is media coverage and we want
to again reach individual families in
local communities and we actually place
a higher emphasis on local media
coverage than we do national media
coverage which is something that I don't
think many national level organizations
do and the reason we focus more on local
media is because we think that
individual parents will sit down around
dinner time watch the local news for
either the weather or for a local sports
team something like that and they'll say
you know what this is something that we
can talk about we want school choice
covered in a very local individualized
way and local news coverage we had 5,600
positive stories this year and since the
inception of school choice week about
twelve to fifteen thousand positive
stories over the course of five years so
very exciting reaching 140 million
people you can see some of the growth we
had the biggest growth in television
news this year over last as a result of
those capital events here's just some of
the some of the different screen caps of
different news stories and I want to
mention as well before we wrap up and
talk about lessons learned that when
we're reaching local communities and
we're building these coalition's and
they're doing events that these are
having significant impact far after the
week is over the Alabama video
was a great example that charter school
legislation looks on track to pass in
Arizona there's a tax credit scholarship
enhancement bill that has been proposed
and promoted by the coalition that
planned an event in Phoenix in Idaho
which is the first time we've ever
worked in Idaho others a big rally in
Boise and they're working on a charter
school funding expansion legislation in
Nevada governor Sandoval is pushing as a
result of or as one result of the rally
there the creation of a voucher tax
credit scholarship program in Texas
there may just be private school choice
for the first time ever and there was a
huge rally there during school choice
week so the examples are numerous and I
could go on and on and on but the basic
premise is we're building coalitions
that will stick together fight with each
other or to fight together instead of
with each other against each other
during the process of legislative
session so they end up getting along
better and you know advancing a common
goal a few lessons that we've learned
and these go back to the barriers that
we're trying to break down with school
choice week is that parents do deserve
more of the spotlight when it comes to
school choice and this is something that
we as folks in the movement need to make
sure is that the voice of local parents
is essential and we need to help tell
their individual stories as opposed to
the stories or the opinions of
organization leaders especially at the
national level school choice is a local
issue this is not a national issue it
has national importance but it is a
local issue that has decided at the
state and local levels there's not much
the federal government can really do
when it comes to school choice and
education and it's important to remember
that as we fight for this common cause
and positive events that are fun in
nature help build strong and lasting
coalition's and I just want to mention
one thing is that you see we have these
yellow scarves some people say it's a
gimmick I think it's great marketing we
do a lot of things that people wouldn't
ordinarily think a school choice
organization should do such as give out
millions of yellow fleece scarves create
a video where kids can learn the moves
to a dance two years ago we chartered a
train and took it across the country in
a whistle-stop tour and yet
these things are marketing gimmicks but
they work because people are looking for
things that are out of the box
interesting i catching you know that
they'll say wait what is that and our
goal is to captivate people's
imagination and we'll do anything we
possibly can to do that in a positive
bright colorful interesting way so by
planning events with folks and building
these coalition's and doing it in a fun
way we're having an impact actually I
should say those organizations are
having an impact in school choice week
is really just the template that they or
the you know blank piece of paper that
they write on and of course the power of
real marketing using real marketing
techniques and applying those marketing
techniques to smart public policy cannot
be understated and those are the
takeaways that I think that we've
learned from school choice week over the
last five years that will continue to
use to guide us in the future and you
know I do think that if we remember
these things and if we remember what I
try to tell people that we in the school
choice movement must never forget that
were really only as good as the stories
we tell and those stories are of the
parents were choosing great schools
regardless of the kind for their kids
their kids are succeeding and
communities are getting better as a
result and it's been an honor to help
tell those stories and I hope to
continue to be able to do that and work
with all of you in telling the stories
of these parents who are in my opinion
heroes so thank you all so much